what is a pyramid the only pyramids
probably everyone remembers are the ones
in Egypt but that's not the only type of
pyramid let's erase this and draw the
pyramids ourselves it looks something
like this notice that it has one two
three and four four vertices let us name
them a b c and d it has just one base
and this base is a triangle its triangle
BCD it has three faces and all of them
are triangles the three triangles are
ABC AC D and abd which is at the back
this is called a triangular pyramid it's
called that because it's base is a
triangle here's another figure it has
one base which is a square and this
figure had four faces all of which are
triangles it has one triangle placed on
each side this is called a square
pyramid since the base is a square
so how do we define a pyramid a pyramid
is a shape which has one base and all
other faces are triangles and the type
of pyramid is derived from its base
triangular base triangular pyramid and
square base square pyramid and remember
all other faces have to be triangles
you